你知道嗎
股市賺最快的兩種玩法
一種是靠股票下跌來賺錢
叫做放空
另一種是當天買當天賣
叫做當沖
很多老手
會把這兩種玩法加在一起
變成組合拳
叫做當沖放空
但是算我拜託你
在搞清楚之前
千萬不要亂玩
因為它雖然賺得很快
但規則也很多
你沒有搞懂就會虧到哭出來
所以今天我會詳細地示範
當沖做空操作步驟
告訴你怎麼利用
股票下跌來賺錢
還有怎麼避開
讓你虧損數十萬的
超大雷區
影片最後
我也會給你一個
我平常也在使用的
高勝率做空當沖技巧
我是小王子
20年資深交易員
靠股票當沖跟波段
連續五年獲利破千萬
我們先從最基本的開始
一般人買股票
都是便宜的時候買
等它上漲的時候再賣掉
可是做空剛好反過來
是在你覺得股票
接下來可能會下跌的時候
先賣出股票
等到它真的跌下去
再買回來
中間的價差就是你的獲利
我舉個簡單的例子
假設有一檔股票現在一百塊
你判斷它今天有機會跌
所以早上先賣掉
後來中午它真的跌到95塊
你再買回來
一張股票一千股
每股差五元
這五千塊就是你的獲利
這就是做空賺錢的邏輯
那什麼叫做當沖
當沖就是進場出場
都要在同一天完成
不能留到明天
所以當沖做空講白了就是
我今天先賣出一檔股票
等它跌下來
同一天我再把它買回來
整筆交易
都要在同一天完成
很多老手
都特別喜歡當沖做空
原因很簡單
就是因為
賺的比較快
因為股票大部分的時候
是慢慢漲
大家都在猶豫
但是跌的時候
很多人想的就是趕快跑
一堆人同時要賣
股價就會用崩的
例如2026年7月7號
開盤之後
國巨的股價
原本還在上下拉扯
漲跌不太明顯
但11點過後
突然有一波下跌
成交量變大
股價越跌
越多人開始賣掉逃命
如果你能抓到這段下跌
這幾小時的獲利
就接近十萬塊
不過聽到這邊
你先不要急著說
這麼好賺
我以後當沖也要來做空
在講解技巧之前
你一定要先搞懂
當沖做空的實際流程
因為它跟一般的股票交易
不太一樣
有兩個地方你一定要注意
只要其中一個沒有搞懂
不但賺不到錢
還可能在很短時間之內
虧一大筆錢
當沖做空有兩種方法
現股當沖放空
跟資券當沖放空
我先教你怎麼操作
現股當沖放空
每個 APP 的操作
可能會有所不同
你先確認三件事就好
第一 交易類別
要選整股
不是零股
第二 要按賣出
第三 找到跟當沖有關的按鈕
這個部分它可能會寫現沖
先賣現沖 賣出當沖
按鈕出現的位置也不一定
可能會在交易類別
也可能是個別的框框
給你打勾
但不管怎麼樣
你就是確認
整股 賣出 現沖
賣完之後
今天收盤前再按買進
把股票買回來
這邊可能會有人覺得
啊我又沒有這檔股票
賣掉不會有問題嗎
不用擔心
這個方法叫做
無券放空
也就是你沒有股票
也可以先賣出
但要記得
一定要在當天買回來
那另外一種資券當沖呢
一樣是選整股
不過下面先選融券賣出
要再買回來的時候
要選融資買進
你就記得
融券賣出 融資買進
這個口訣
而且要注意
資券當沖
你要先開設信用戶才能做
申請至少要三個條件
年滿20歲
資券戶開戶滿三個月
最近一年之內成交超過十筆
有的狀況還會要求你
附上財力證明
那這邊整理一下
現股當沖做空
是在同一天先賣後買
交易稅可以減半
資券當沖則是
先融券賣出
再融資買進
另外要先申請信用帳戶
才能操作
而且要注意
資券當沖
是沒有交易稅的優惠喔
那可能有人會覺得
資券當沖又沒有優惠
還很麻煩
還要開信用戶
到底有誰會用
這就要說到
現股做空當沖最大的危險
也就是很多新手
會忽略的地方
就是我們剛剛講到的
無券放空
你手上沒有股票
但是可以先賣掉
當天要再買回來
但是如果碰到漲停板
沒有人要賣
買不回來
就會發生一件很可怕的事
券商會幫你
去跟別人借股票
這部分的利息非常高
最高一天是7%
你沒有聽錯
是一天7%喔
借到股票之後
隔天一早
不管它是多少錢
券商都會強制幫你買回來
一套流程下來
常常會損失
20%到30%
因為你本來做空失敗
就已經賠掉10%
再加上7%的利息
隔天一早如果又繼續漲停
就會虧更多
但這還不是最慘的狀況
因為隔天一早
有可能一開盤
繼續漲停鎖死
想買還是買不到
這時候就要再多付一天
7%的利息
隔一天再繼續買
直到買到為止
你不要覺得這不可能
幾個月前
2026年3月17號
AI 股永擎就發生過這種事
當時它連續漲了好幾天
很多人想說差不多該跌了吧
跑去做空
結果當天開盤沒多久
股價就從
201漲停鎖死
變成223塊
一堆人買不回來
而且隔天開盤繼續漲停板
沒有人要賣
還是買不到
變成245
直到第三天
哇 終於可以買到了
多少錢
兩百六十八點五
三天前
你從201塊開始買
現在268塊
這中間差了快7萬塊
而且還要多付兩次
每天7%的借券費
差不多3萬塊
加起來3天10萬塊
直接蒸發
聽起來超級可怕對吧
但碰到這種情況
你先不要慌
還有得救
你如果做空失敗買不回來
第一件事
就是在兩點半之前
用最快的速度
打電話給你的營業員
跟他說你要把這筆交易
改成融券賣出
也就是說
你拿出股價的90%
當做保證金
跟券商借這支股票
這樣做的好處就是
你的利息會
會變得非常非常的低
從原本的每天7%
變成每年0.4%左右
3萬多塊變成5塊
也可以讓你稍微喘口氣
不用隔天就一定要買回來
但這邊還是要注意兩點
第一點
每家券商可以借給你的股票
是有限的
你想改成融券
不一定會成功
而且融券有一個數字
叫做維持率
如果這個數字太低
券商就會擔心你虧太多
還不出錢
會強制你把股票買回來
也就是大家俗稱的緞頭
那這部分的細節
我們有做一部影片
我會把它放在
右上角的資訊卡
等一下看完這集
就可以點過去看
搞懂做空當沖
要怎麼操作之後
接下來才是進入實戰
做空當沖
要提高勝率
安全穩定地賺錢
最重要的三件事
第一 提前找到今天特別弱
容易跌的股票
而不是看到它下跌
就衝進去追
第二 找到合適的進場訊號
做空最常看的就是
支撐跟壓力
支撐有點像股價的地板
股價跌到這裡
比較容易停下來
如果連這個位置都跌破
那代表接下來股價
高機率會持續變弱
壓力也就是股價
短期的天花板
股價漲到這裡
常常會被壓下來
如果股價反彈之後
突破不了天花板
那就代表接下來股價
會比這個價格還低
你從這個高點放空
就可以賺一段
但你要注意
沒有什麼是100%穩賺的
所以真正的高手
在進場之前
就已經做好第三點
提前設定
安全的出場點跟停損點
保住獲利避開大賠
這三點說起來很簡單
但實戰上處處都是細節
這些東西只花這幾分鐘
老實說真的很難學會
所以我辦了一場
免費的直播講座
我會先給你
我統計20年的股票清單
用來快速找出
隔天很容易下跌的股票
也用實際的圖表
清楚地說明
進場的壓力跟支撐怎麼看
怎麼操作
現在點資訊欄連結
就可以免費報名
你試看看就知道有沒有用
很多同學用這些方法
都有不錯的成績
你可能很難想像
他們原本
連當沖是什麼都不知道
現在就可以每個月
幫自己加薪好幾萬
直播講座名額有限
如果看不到的話
代表暫時額滿了
如果你覺得今天影片
對你有幫助
請你幫我按讚訂閱
開啟小鈴鐺
也可以跟我分享你的看法
我是小王子
我們下次見